Dada is once again on the loose in its
birthplace many Zurich museums have
organized exhibitions to celebrate the
movement and explore why it has been so
earth-shattering but what does data mean
now the current director of the Cabaret
Voltaire puts it in perspective does
Elsa so Samia data is more than the DA
tests more than an art movement it's
much more it designates an attitude
formed back then in reaction to the
zeitgeist and that attitude is still
valid today tamil dear hope they gave me
but in October and zeitgeist I nameless
the Russian punk band [ __ ] Riot could
be seen as a latter-day example of data
performance art stroke protests that rub
salt into wounds and cabaret voltaire
where Dadaism was once unleashed on the
world will be celebrating the movement
all year with performances by Dada's
descendants this is a white white blue
sea and this is a tiny little boat comes
across the sea with loads of step rest
for people and it drops back down to the
ground to the ground to the ground to
the truth